as promised we're looking at a question
3 which has this table already provided
for you so you don't need to redraw this
though you will actually need to put
some extra information on the question
says complete this table so it was not
that bad a way to spend the time let's
have a look at what the question is
actually providing us you've got a
student investigating whether there's
any relationship this person's looking
for correlation essentially between
those who choose extension 1 mathematics
so that's these guys here and those who
choose extension 1 English which is this
guy over here at his school copy you can
put the table by filling in the total so
let's have a think first about what this
is telling us you've got em for
extension 1 maths Eve for extension 1
English and then you've got these other
things which have bars over them we know
what this symbol means what is being
referred to here it's the confident very
good so very simply extension 1 English
people who are three extension one
English and so on for mathematics so the
first thing I want us to do is put some
totals onto this you can see this will
be the good color you can see if we want
to go across to work out everyone who's
doing extension one English and we're
just gonna add up these two don't use
your calculator mr. brain what are you
getting over here thank you very much
56 these look bigger but this still
tillable 137 very good now this was with
English and non English as we go down
let's see here take away 5 124 and 69 ok
so we've got our totals here except for
one that one in the bottom right hand
corner how do I calculate that one so
one thing I could do is out of these
guys add up these guys who would like to
do that a few heads up a few hands down
is there anything else I could do to
come up with a total for all of the
students in this school if I'm not gonna
add up all of them some of it a lot of
you did not put your hands up what else
can we do well these four original ones
right what do you think he's a key
we can either add up these guys or we
can add up these guys and they should
give us the same total should they not
because the way we got this number was
by doing these two the way we got this
number by getting these two which is the
same constituents part that gave us
these numbers just did a different
breakdown right it should be 193 very
good so this is our total total all of
the students in here okay now this is a
helpful tool to understand what's going
on but I want to remind you it's not the
only way that we can diagrammatically or
represent what's happening here and in
fact this might be what I'm gonna draw
down here and you will need 0 this one
may be more helpful for us as we answer
the next parts this is what we call of
course a Venn diagram right now the
reason why this is going to be useful to
us is we have well number we've got two
categories and also importantly we have
an overlap between them this is if we
call this guy extension one English and
extension one mass which number belongs
in here have a look carefully in here
these are the people who do extension
one English and also do extension one
math so that's this number up here in
fact let's start there let's put our 29
over here I'm gonna give you a second
can you fill in the rest of the numbers
that should belong in our Venn diagram
there should be three more numbers you
need to write go ahead and put them in
the spots that you think are appropriate
[Music]
[Music]
well let's have a think together then I
can hear your reasoning which is
excellent let's do this as a group I'm
gonna start over here this part of the
diagram this is people who do extension
one English but be Matt they're outside
of this circle they don't do extension
with math so which number is that
representative they do extension one
English so what that correspond to see
on the table is the top row right but
they don't do math so that's the don't
do extension one that that's this column
isn't it
so this is the number that belongs over
here right go into the opposite side
people do extension one Matz but not
extension one English have a look
95 very good and then there's that last
number doesn't belong in the circles at
all it's non extension one English not
extension it's a 42 so it's outside this
diagram right over here
42 good to go and of course if we took
all four numbers we should still add up
to 193 quick question for you and it's
not a rhetorical question which of these
representations of the situation is
better which one is better will you
recognize oh you like the table what do
you like about the table it's just clear
what do you see that's clearer here that
you don't see here
yep yep
fantastic okay I was only come back to
that point a second Leslie do you agree
or disagree
you think the Venn diagram is better
bim's fighting words okay it's really
okay umm you want to justify that
argument Leslie it's interesting it's
interesting we heard clear and
complicated the same words to describe
sorry different words to describe the
same thing here's what I'm going to say
to you right and the reason why I have
both of these on the board just like
tools in a toolbox tools are better
according to the purpose that you want
to use them for right I would say this
is going to be better if what you want
to see is all these turtles
imagine trying to put all these numbers
also onto this diagram it would just be
a disaster right seeing it here in this
row in this column tells me exactly what
it indicates right however what I like
about this is it shows there's a
relationship between these numbers right
this 29 and this 27 interact with each
other they tell me like when I look at
this if you were to ask me like where
are the English people I feel like I can
see that clear on here and I don't have
to do that as you said Lizzy they're
navigating through which Row is which
like that's not a and a which one is
that's quite confusing right if you're
not good with your notation surround you
want to add a different point sure yeah
this complement stuff right whereas this
it's like am I in there or am I out of
here it kind of visually tells you now
the point is as we go through and I want
you to scan your eyes now a down part be
one two three and four right we are kind
of going to use both of these tools in
different ways and what's important for
you is that you know number one how to
create these that they represent the
same situation number two when to use
which one which one has advantages